the first glimpse of a president on the
day he went to court Mr Trump
brought Donald Trump to this moment in
U.S history
with his son Eric at his Golf Club
outside Miami and with his legal team
America's 45th president was about to be
the first to be charged under the
Espionage Act
president Trump how are you feeling
great he says and then into the armored
vehicle for the Convoy to court
[Applause]
a slow drive-by outside the resort and
as every second of this was captured he
was on his own social media site Witch
Hunt he posted
at court the crowds had swelled for a
spectacle that we wouldn't see
away from the cameras on the 13th floor
in courtroom number three president
Trump along with his aide Walt nowter
surrendered themselves to the duty
magistrate they were under arrest on
federal charges
yeah
outside one of the president's lawyers
was commanding the Airways owning the
moment and with more than a hint of the
way Mr Trump wants this to play out
the decision to pursue charges against
President Trump while turning a blind
eye to others
is an emblematic of the corruption that
we have here
we are at a turning point in our
nation's history the truth is that the
cases she mentions against Joe Biden and
others are under investigation
but if the aim is to pit the people
against the institutions that are
supposed to hold the country together
well then his National support base is
certainly strong enough to deepen the
division
[Applause]
and it was left for his lawyer to say we
most certainly plead not guilty
then as the Convoy left this
he is an anti-trump protester
and he was quickly arrested
[Applause]
[Music]
and then this day of spectacles moved on
to the city's most famous Cuban Cafe and
a photo opportunity
foreign
prompt you on the face of it
and of course and it was President Trump
who had the last word I think it's a rig
deal here we have a rigged country we
have a country that's corrupt we have a
country that's got no borders we have a
country that's got nothing but problems
he'll head now to New Jersey his golf
course there and a news conference later
Mark Stone Sky News in Miami